but very simply
joe biden could have done this right
easily yeah yeah what would he have done
different
so in your opinion anyway for us i'm
going to build a foundation for this one
first this is going to be about a three
minute kind of piece
but it's going to require layers so if
you're looking at the the situation in
afghanistan you're looking at multiple
layers of problems multiple layers of
failures one of them being um this is
going to piss off a lot of people but
generally speaking afghanistan is a
failed state
so it's not a unified people it doesn't
have a unified government it's it's it's
constantly in a state of upheaval right
so if you're going to look at countries
like china america russia germany
great britain
mexico even
afghanistan doesn't it did doesn't that
culturally does not have the unity that
even america has in our own fractured
nonsense
right so for them as a culture some of
it is still very much so i'm i'm really
only loyal to my tribe which makes sense
but they don't have the they don't have
the kind of trickling up effective of at
least some sense of loyalty or some
sense of
unified cultural identity there are a
lot of spurious connections between them
but there's not a single unified
cultural identity in there some of this
is because of things that we just don't
understand in the west and some of them
are things that are a little bit more
nuanced than just tribalism but there
are issues within the afghan culture
that she saw because we spent 20 years
and a lot well we spent all this time
and money building an american or an
afghan military and as soon as they saw
the taliban coming they're like ah you
know here's the guns we're good they
gave up the weapons so that's the first
layer the second layer
is that so much of the american
military's leadership was more concerned
about the opinions of people that don't
even like them
or are actively working against them
they're so worried about american news
agencies writing hit pieces on them
because then their political career is
done
because once you get past a certain
level in the american military on the
officer scale you become an inherently
political position
and so the american body politics i mean
this at this point you get that that
first i mean you become an officer
you're a politician exactly well it i
don't even know what the lieutenant
looks like anymore but i would expect
something because if you're gonna be if
you're gonna put that much investment
into it you're have to be at least
hoping to look far enough in that you're
gonna go on for like a kernel and move
your way up there and then the third
part that comes into this one is the
american cultural issue
of
we didn't
as a culture
come to terms with what we were trying
to accomplish there nor did we as a
culture believe in our own
values enough to try to transpose them
into this country if we think certain
things are good like we're not even like
representative government as a value we
did not pass that on to the afghan
people or they did not root it in they
did not take root of that so we were
talking about
afghanistan as a multi-layered problem
you're dealing with bureaucrats making
rules of engagement
for the people who are on the ground uh
in in the words of a good friend of mine
you have people who are non-threats
that and what i mean by non-threat isn't
they have no strategic value they have
no if if you if the if the an opposing
force were to encounter them they
wouldn't even take them seriously right
that so this person is so disconnected
from the american military the concept
of war but somehow they're being allowed
to make rules of engagement right for
navy seals army rangers delta force guys
where now you've got the guys who signed
the paper chose to do it and don't get
me wrong it's those people are
responsible too because they listen to
bad leadership if they did when they did
if they did and and it's not just a
blanket statement well the leadership is
bad because you're your own person
american rugged individualism begins at
the person and the american military
gave that up as the american culture has
been giving that up so layer one
afghanistan was never going to become a
glorious utopia layer two the the more
concerned about what my american
constituents are gonna say and then
layer three is on a cultural level we
gave up the fact that i as an individual
it's my responsibility if i'm the one
carrying the the firearm i am the one
who's responsible for it and it's not
that the people on the ground gave that
up it's that their political leadership
took that from them going back to
nicholas nicholas naseem tuleb
if you read
if you want to read three books of his
black swan anti-fragile skin in the game
skin in the game means if i'm not if i'm
the guy on the ground i know that i can
make decisions because i know that if
i'm looking at a combatant or
non-combatant i can make that decision
if my leadership does not believe that i
can make that decision but instead puts
rules of engagement which i don't even
get to engage that part of my mind
then they have failed the the the
apparatus that is the american concept
of war failed in afghanistan which is no
surprise why china would be willing to
push it yeah this is also um covered in
the concept of the strategic e4 right
the idea that when you look at some of
this stuff from a fourth generation
warfare perspective the idea that optics
are warfare right so suddenly an e4 tip
of the spear
right you're thinking oh well i'm the
bottom of this echelon i have this whole
hierarchy above me
giving me the rules of order it's making
these strategic decisions giving me
commander's intent but instead because
you're the one who's there and then
you've got someone on the other side
that's taking your picture or that's
portraying your actions or misportraying
your actions right you are now the face
of us government policy you're the face
of the you know or in their terms the
way they would like to portray it of
course as the as the uh evil western
occupying empire that is uh crushing
their land for 20 years and let's face
it if you were you know if you were
someone in afghanistan who's 18 years
old right now right you don't know what
911 was that's like something you read
about you know or maybe you saw a video
of but you just know that you've been
growing living in a country your entire
life as you've been growing up and
seeing foreign soldiers walking around
occupying your country telling your
government what to do and then you've
got some people saying oh just go along
with them even though they don't speak
your language they don't have your
values they don't share your religion
they don't share your culture and then
you've got another group that says no
follow us let's get rid of them let's
talk about the rules of engagement
though let's talk have you guys i'm
assuming you probably have experienced
things where it's like it makes no sense
absolutely absolutely absolutely you
know so yeah elaborate force cooper team
leader 2013 was was explained that i
have to tell my my
uh the people that i'm in charge of i'm
a team leader i'm in charge of guys i
have to explain to them that in the
event there is a man standing in his
doorway with a belt fed machine gun
shooting at your people uh we are not
allowed to return fire with effective
weaponry because there's the possibility
that somebody might be standing behind
him in his house what
about fed machine gun in his door yep
and so the appropriate response at that
time was to pull back to a safe
situation where you can contain it
without receiving effective fire okay
now we're using military jargon well you
can contain the situation without
receiving effective fire which is
anywhere between 50 yards and 300 yards
or whatever and then wait for him to
stop shooting
what that's amazing
how
well i mean when they run out eventually
yeah
okay so let's let's make another very
important distinction when your job is
you are in a special operations unit and
you're tasked with performing things
like a night raid where you go we're
going to go after perfect most famous
night raid ever going after osama bin
laden right so if they had told the guys
going after osama bin laden that you're
not allowed to shoot unless you're being
shot at
okay think about that dynamic really
quickly yeah you're being employed by
the american military to go after a
specific target but you're supposed to
also act like you're beat cop in chicago
and you're not allowed to actually
engage with the targets that you know
are armed and preparing to fight against
you until you have some sort of check
mark from somebody else who has no skin
in the game that confirms that you have
received effective fire from somebody
this is really interesting we were
looking at this graph the other day that
lydia had pulled up showing the
different jobs by political affiliation
and it's like
you know army ranger probably tends to
be more conservative and then bureaucrat
who sets policy for armies army ranger
probably tends to be more liberal or
something to that effect you're going to
get people who don't do the job telling
you how to do the job dude they
commanded you
to as a tactic a battle tech to his way
for the enemy to stop fighting that was
your tactic that's a great tactic that
was also our strategy it wasn't it
wasn't a tactic it was enforced by law
if i broke that because i was like oh
you know what i'm a designated marksman
i know that i can make this shot at this
yardage and i know that i'm not being
shot at right now i am fully trained and
confident in that ability have the
equipment and the situation that
presents it if i even completed that
then i would go home from the mission
and have to face lawyer well not lawyer
but i have to face an entire effectively
court appearance overseas by americans
basically trying to figure out whether
or not they can throw me in is this like
does this happen where someone will by
the way you've got you've probably got
three or four activist jags looking to
make rank that look at you and say aha
we've got a situation where somebody
broke the rules they're not looking at
what your mission was or what your
objective was or what the context of
that particular objective was they're
looking at how can i make rank as a jag
that's a military lawyer by going after
somebody prosecuting them yeah yeah and
win precisely so you could save three
people's lives and then they would
probably irrelevant does that happen
that's completely wrong you didn't save
their lives you just failed to
accidentally hurt them right like if you
like if there was gonna be a fire fight
and the guy with the machine was gonna
mow down three of your guys and then
they were gonna mow him down but you
prevented that by sniping the guy how
did you know he was going to attack your
people yeah they're yeah right there's
no way to know he was opening fire with
a machine gun how do we know that he's
trying to hurt someone um what if he's
got a machine gun and he's like
literally feeding the belt in it while
staring at you frantically do people go
through this court process knowing that
they save people's lives by disobeying
an order and they're like you know what
i did the right thing and then they get
their careers trashed and they're thrown
in prison and yes they do not care
they do not care remember there there
was eve i mean it goes even further i'm
doing this with um i don't know how much
we can talk about uh
the
uh
i don't even know how to say it but the
um
basically there was a situation where
there would be underage uh boys on on
and around
us military bases and i'm trying to be
very youtube friendly with this
and we know and there's there are
specific terms for that i have no idea
whether youtube has an issue with the
afghani terms for that yeah probably but
i'm just not going to say it it's a
horrifying um but there would be times
where i'm sure you know these stories as
well
where u.s soldiers would say i can't
take this anymore i can't live with
myself and they would step up and try to
stop it times where it was happening
where young boys are being abused or
being abused
boys were being abused but it was known
about they were told to shut up about it
i mean the new york times has covered
this extensively um this was being done
by
afghan military officers police officers
and even times where people lose their
careers get prosecuted for getting
involved with this and trying to stop it
right so you're trying to stop them so
not even talking about rules of
engagement which which is obviously
completely a separate thing this is just
you know right and wrong right kind of
stuff and they say well oh that's just a
cultural difference you you just you
know you have to let them is that what
we're trying to prop up
you're you're a company commander you're
in charge of
130 guys plus a couple of more and then
your company is attached to a afghan
company
and you're supposed to be working with
each other they're well they're attached
to you fine um and you
having because you understand that you
need to integrate your forces so that
they can work well together otherwise
it's just going to be two completely
useless bodies on the well one's going
to be very useful and one's going to be
very lost
you can figure that out for yourself um
land nav is not an officer especially uh
so but you can take this issue and
you're working with some of us can read
compasses
in 1970 oh
so
uh back to the joke um uh you know i
went to ranger school i know how that
works uh but so in that one you have and
you're working with you're working with
a you have a
host nation cohort and you know they're
participating in not just casual
corruption like issues where it's not
just money being exchanged but many many
worse things and instead of being able
to say this is not the what we're going
to represent to our country we're not
going to this because they're definitely
they're an inherently a reflection of on
you
you're the if the americans protect the
people who do the bad things then they
are
in part and parcel responsible for it at
least within the cultural concept
and so when you as a commander say we're
we're going to put a stop to this in
this connected force and you get
sidelined because it wasn't politically
operative or optimal that's what you're
dealing with right yup
man
virtue be damned
until you talk about the ptsd
ramifications of that you talk about the
22 veteran suicide today
that obviously this is something that's
driving um you know and and you're right
by the way that's that is the different
cultural values it is a very western
cultural value that if you see some like
see something say something how many
times do we say that right but that's
not the same in all cultures right in
other cultures they'll say well i don't
know that person and i'm not involved in
that so why should i get involved we
would encounter villages towns and areas
where a person would be
targeted we would our person would be
targeted because he was
100 confirmed being a bomb manufacturer
intended to do harm on whoever right he
there and and and there and they have
their little compound with their walls
and they in that compound they're
building
explosives for the purpose of maiming
and killing american soldiers and afghan
citizens
their neighbor will know about it and
say it's not on my property so i don't
care correct
it's i do not care that my neighbor
oh yeah yeah my neighbor and well that's
one dynamic right they'll be like oh
yeah my neighbor works for the taliban
he builds bombs and you're like thanks
but then you then you also have to deal
with the secondary layer of you and i
are neighbors you're the american
government and you and i are in a feud
and i'll be like
you know i want some of his land uh but
i won't tell you that i'll be like yeah
he builds bombs and so you right so it's
like that's like the soviet union now
that my friends who are who who are from
there have said similar stories where
you know i was hanging out in an
apartment and my friend told me that
she's like hey you know the apartment
next to this one
you know back in the during the soviet
union there were two neighbors and they
were feuding with each other so the
person who lived here just called the
communist party and said they were
badmouthing the party and a day later
their apartment was empty yep
it's a nightmarish way to live man
war screwed up because you're talking
about values you talked about american
value at least a western value is this
idea that we
know our neighbors and we at least hold
them to a certain level of
accountability to some extent at least
to some i mean that might yeah like if
you're in the u.s right and i see my
next door neighbor like like beating
their dog or something or their kid or
whatever it is like you're gonna call
the cops most likely yeah you are going
i mean nine times out of ten someone in
the u.s is gonna say all right i'm gonna
pick up the phone and do something about
that because that's wrong right i see
this wrong other parts of the world it's
hey that's their dog that's their kid
maybe they did something wrong
yeah and there's a left and right limit
to that for sure sure because then you
run into you know the uh then you run
into the minneapolis problem well they
didn't have a black lives matter flag
outside their house so let's burn it
down next well you've seen like the
riots in hamburg during i think it was
the g20 or whatever all the windows are
smashed at except for one these there's
a photo all the windows smashed out
except for one and it's got the
communist fists in the window that's the
one that gets that it gets it gets left
alone
but i i i've been studying a lot of like
war history and a lot of times it's like
you know the army goes into the city
they they kill most of the male fighters
and then they rape the women and pillage
and burn the city this doesn't always
happen but it was pretty pretty frequent
like normal the commander be like okay
he lets his troops pillage because if he
doesn't they're gonna mutiny and kill
him so he lets his troops do but we've
like gone the opposite direction with
like the geneva convention and american
military
proper like taking make sure you don't
upset your your your foes before you
kill them um and i wonder if we've gone
too far like war
the one that tries to fight with with
honor is the one that loses i mean
that's we learned that in the
revolutionary war you see that world war
one i'm not i wouldn't be so cynical as
not willing to fight with honor i think
that's a bit of a hyper simplification
okay you're definitely an example of
where it of where your example an
example of what your uh your uh
metaphor your example does come out is
so you go into an afghan town you kick
down a door
and
and and you find the character that
you're looking for now you have to pay
the family the american equivalent of
the fanciest door
to the family because you kicked on the
door because could you have done it
without kicking down the door like dude
he's a terrorist
why do i have to pay the family for the
door
well because you did damage to the
property like we were going after him
because he was facilitating
insert one of these issues he was doing
one of these things like we didn't just
go after him willy nilly because his
name is whatever
it's you know you go after a guy he's
building bombs he's facilitating
fighters he's in he's he's he's he's uh
recruiting recruiting he's whatever i
mean you could figure out any of the
answer what so so you go into the
village you you have your target
structure you hit the building
and then afterwards you're like well now
we have to pay the family for the door
american police don't if they kick a
door down they don't pay for the door oh
american citizens would you look at that
american police and military differences
there's a lot of big
ethical and moral questions that arise
from what's going on in afghanistan and
the first is you know you mention the
horrible things that they do they're
this really disgusting practice that we
can't really talk about on youtube but
it's it's child abuse
and and actually that that's one of the
things just to get into the more
complexity of it that's one of the
things that the taliban was against and
so
one of the ways that they originally and
omar and kandahar were raising were
rising to power was because they were
were essentially they would find out
about stuff like that going on and then
execute people in the streets and so
people would say they were so sick of it
they'd say okay well let's go for this
extreme reaction let's let's join in
with these guys because at least they'll
do something about it well so i think
about the u.s being in this foreign land
where a bunch of people don't like them
as you pointed out they don't speak the
language they don't even look like you
they're a bunch of imperial powerful
troopers who come in and tell you how to
live and what you have to do and there
are people who are there who are like no
way they were going to resist by any
means necessary the problem i see is i
don't think we should have been there if
we wanted to go after al-qaeda that i
understand sticking around for
nation-building and occupying this
country results in people resisting you
and for all of the really horrifying
things i would personally wish they were
not doing i don't know if that is
justification for the us being the world
police for every single issue like that
because if we were going to go into
every country where they had a problem
like that we'd be occupying the you know
uh north africa for for everything
that's happening like with a slave truck
i could sit here for hours and tell you
about you know country after country
that's that's conducting
moral atrocities
there's always going to be a rwanda out
there if we're going to go after
somebody though we better go after them
that's the issue that i have this is
what this is where i come from the
underground guy right exactly so it's
like again if you've trained guys you
spend millions of dollars to train dudes
to be really good at what they're doing
where are the american when this was the
initial the the initial operations in
afghanistan october 2011 was just that
look at those kind of things right like
look at the the abilities of the of the
american warfighter jawbreaker right i
don't remember because if it was if
we're talking about like 2001 it's like
jawbreaker anaconda like some of those
really early and i was really young
of course of course um and and i will
not pretend to be the most astute
historian in american military history
um because
especially when you look at the global
warranty gets bigger the more you look
into it oh yeah but a very simple answer
is
you let the people who you've trained to
do the job do the job
you let you you don't you do not put
artificial inhibition artificial
barriers for them so when we're talking
about navy seals army rangers delta
force
uh special forces guys it's like okay
what's the mission dismantle the
taliban's network in this area okay go
do that and go do that to the best of
your ability and just keep doing that
until
you've accomplished the the dissolution
of the taliban network no we don't
really want to go after the taliban
network anymore now we want to engage in
nation building because it looks better
for our constituents thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time